Hollywood loves remakes and reboots.
Returning to time-tested franchises is irresistible
to big studios that know nostalgia is a hell
of a drug, and that there's plenty of new
money to be made when reviving an old cash
cow.
There are so many remakes in the works, in
fact, that some might have slipped past your
radar.
Here are a few awesome remakes you probably
didn't know were happening.
Child's Play
Remakes are nothing new in the horror genre.
And now it looks like a certain Good Guy doll
will terrorize a new generation of moviegoers.
According to the Hollywood Reporter, MGM is
"fast-tracking" a Child's Play remake with
Norwegian director Lars Klevberg, produced
by the same guys who produced the 2017 It
remake.
There's no word yet on who will star, but
as for the plot, Collider reports that the
new Child's Play will take a page from the
Stranger Things playbook, as it will involve
a group of kids working together to fight
the demonic doll.
But things might get a bit messy in the Child's
Play universe.
Universal Studios still intends to produce
a Chucky TV series and more sequels as part
of the original Child's Play franchise, all
starring Brad Dourif, the guy who's voiced
the wisecracking killer since 1988.
"No more Mr. Good Guy!"
The Witches
According to Variety, Forrest Gump and Back
to the Future director Robert Zemeckis is
remaking 1990's The Witches, a freaky film
based one of Roald Dahl's creepiest novels.
The plot involves a young boy on vacation
who discovers a coven of witches that plans
on turning England's children into mice.
The original starred Anjelica Huston as the
villainous Grand High Witch, with a wonderfully
over-the-top German accent.
The new version doesn't have a cast or a director
as of the making of this video, but it will
reportedly be more faithful to Dahl's novel.
Guillermo del Toro was supposed to cast his
own spell on the remake, but now he's only
co-producing, alongside Gravity director Alfonso
Cuaron.
With four Oscars and dozens of other awards
between the two of them, that's a lot of talent
behind the scenes, which gives us high hopes
for this remake.
The Sword in the Stone
Continuing their streak of producing live-action
remakes of their classic animated films, Disney
is reportedly working on a new version of
1963's The Sword in the Stone.
This whimsical cartoon told the familiar story
of a young King Arthur training under the
magical and musical tutelage of the wise old
wizard Merlin.
"Hail King Arthur!
Hail King Arthur!"
The first film was a lighthearted romp that
involved enchanted dishes, squirrel romance,
and a shapeshifting wizard battle.
The remake, however, might be a tad darker.
It's being directed by Juan Carlos Fresnadillo,
the guy behind 28 Weeks Later, and the screenplay
will be written by Bryan Cogman, who's written
multiple episodes of Game of Thrones.
So when the movie makes its premiere on Disney's
upcoming streaming service, expect something
a bit more grown-up than the original.
Uptown Saturday Night
Released in 1974, the original Uptown Saturday
Night features a big-name cast, including
Sidney Poitier, Richard Pryor, Harry Belafonte
and Bill Cosby.
The plot involves two buddies who get held
up after visiting a nightclub, and during
the robbery, they lose a lottery ticket worth
$50,000.
Determined to get the ticket back, the duo
start searching for the crooks who made off
with their fortune.
Anchorman director Adam McKay was initially
supposed to direct the upcoming remake, according
to the Hollywood Reporter, and the lead roles
were meant for Will Smith and Denzel Washington.
Sadly, that never panned out, but now Kevin
Hart is tackling the project.
There's no word yet on who will star opposite
him, but we do know the screenplay will be
written by Kenya Barris, the creator of ABC's
Black-ish.
Point Blank
Frank Grillo and Anthony Mackie have played
bitter enemies in the Captain America franchise,
trading put-downs and punches as Crossbones
and Falcon, respectively.
Now the two are going to butt heads again
in a remake of Point Blank, a 2010 French
action flick which boasts an impressive 91
percent on Rotten Tomatoes.
According to Collider, Mackie will play a
nurse whose pregnant wife gets kidnapped by
the brother of a hospitalized murder suspect
who wants to make a trade.
As you can probably guess, Grillo plays the
murder suspect, and based off his antagonistic
chemistry with Mackie in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, we're pretty sure Point Blank will
be one intense thriller when it premieres
on Netflix.